but guys hey you know what I want to
thank each and every one of you guys for
spending your weekend here at the
amazing Las Vegas comic-con it is really
oh my gosh there are a ton of Deadpool
cosplayers in here
because I see Bob Ross out here there's
a lot and I see some cool t-shirts but
of course I mean there's a ton of
Deadpool fans and we have the creator of
Deadpool coming out here in just one
second but what I think yeah I know we
got excited people here but what I think
what's really cool is did anybody here
go to the gym Starlin Jorge Perez panel
earlier okay you know what was awesome
about that is that we had all these
people that created these concepts or
inspired these concepts that were in the
movies and this is awesome Thanos cool
character came out in the early 70s you
know it's it's you know 2019 and he's
snapping fingers and and kicking ass all
over the Marvel Universe but you know
what's awesome is that this creator that
we're bringing out the guy who created
Deadpool the guy that created cable the
guy that created x-force the guy that
started Image Comics he's not didn't
just do it in the past he's doing it
over and over and over again with tons
of brand new creations right now and
that's the best part about the amazing
comic conventions is that we create we
connect the creators with the fans if
you guys are the best fans around this
is a great panel it's going to be
presented by Collider once again check
out Collider they are the destination
spot on the internet for the best pop
culture and we have coy Jean duro coming
on out I want to thank you coy thanks so
much for being here he's got his
Deadpool shirt on how's it going guys
so I've liked Deadpool so loudly and for
so long it turned into a career it is
the weirdest thing that's happened to me
is Deadpool being what I get to yell
about for a living so it is my absolute
great pleasure to introduce Rob Liefeld
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm going to talk for a couple
minutes and then I'm gonna let this man
just go because you want to hear from
him so there's a literally one chair
because I'm gonna pacer and let them in
oh no I'm getting a chair there's two
chairs but we're gonna wear D like a few
minutes of me let you guys have some
questions and then Rob has plenty to say
so we're gonna let them I got to start
off with we'll get to Deadpool but right
now it's major next season because major
X is selling out in a way that I haven't
seen happen in a very long time and I
think that's a testament to a lack of a
certain flavor of comic in the industry
that you're supplying and I really love
the fact that we have a full action
spectacle insanity of a comic book and I
want to know when you had this idea how
it came to be and how you came to tell
marvel like no we're doing an action
book with lots of punching coy I'm gonna
get to that in a minute first I want to
say thank you to anyone who's here all
you awesome Vegas fans this show is the
best show every year in and out thanks I
love for you even come and spend some
time with us I love seeing you guys I
love that this show celebrates comics
the koi is my buddy I've done a couple
shows with him and he honored me with
this awesome shirt today and is helping
pay my kids college by wearing it 13 of
these not kidding Deadpool time yeah
purchase something Deadpool you're
showing the Liefeld family love and we
thank you for it I feel like I should be
a commercial icon in the middle of the
night now on Fox and when you purchase a
Deadpool anyway so he'll curse at you
anyway so matrix here's the deal there's
so much love for my peer group myself
Todd McFarlane Jim Lee wolf potage CEO
Jim Valentino Eric Larson Marc Silvestri
I got him I got them all my in my image
compadres you guys we grew up on comics
in the 70s if you ever follow me on my
Instagram stories or my mainly my
Instagram stories sometimes I just want
to kind of share my thoughts with you
and like I swear to you I will not show
you I will not tell the publisher
you'd be surprised it's not you thinking
but a publisher put out a 30 page comic
recently and I kid you not and it's a
big book not a single piece of action is
in that comic not a single fist is rated
B one thing I'm like don't you take my
eggs like nobody does they literally
talk in a graveyard they talk on a
balcony they talk in a living room they
talk back in the living room they go
back to the graveyard and then they're
in the lawn on the lawn and I'm like
this is not a comic I can enjoy on any
level like just put a kid it's me and
koi talking right now not gonna make a
great comic makes a nice panel we grew
up with the energy that Marvel Comics
was putting out in the 70s which were
the greatest con okay apparently you had
my idols jim Starlin towards perez those
guys on here earlier we were influenced
by them and what you kept got from us is
what we got from them and what they got
is from two mad geniuses who are no
longer with us
Stanley Jack Kirby also Steve you know
yeah I mean these guys so I think major
Epps you know it's funny I read some
interviews before it hit and I've never
gotten a good interview of my entire
career
never the next good one I get will be
the only one I've ever received working
on entire career I'm like I don't know
but anyway trying to think of a pop star
that everybody buys their album and
nobody says they like and like but I
don't want to do that to those pop stars
hey no no I love her so no I love Katy
Perry's so anyway Katy come to my house
and hang out with my kids I'm so anyway
the thing is that a couple of the
reviews are like this is just an
action-packed mindless and I got to be
honest I read that I'm like oh man
the book is sunk cut to Marvel going Rob
it sold out a week in advance
and it really was and every issue you
guys have bought major X thank you it's
you we just do the work but sometimes we
have a connection that work connects
because my characters are throwing up
like they're throwing blows Prince Namor
the Submariner was created to fight the
thing okay
and Luke Cage was created to fight iron
fist and the Fantastic Four and
everybody like they weren't meant to
talk they're not what is that it's
because some of these writers think
they're Aaron Sorkin and they're like yo
man some producer it's gonna read my
comic and ask me to write a screenplay
like I'm gonna make it verbose I'm like
can I just go back to my rack and get a
George Perez comic cuz that comic moves
and can I get a Jim Starlin comic cuz
that's people were punching in jim
Starlin comics elbows fist knees and
they were making speeches but they were
hitting each other okay make a speech
while you're hitting each other and that
is the art of comic books it is a medium
where you can make a speech all hitting
each other man you know if Colossus and
Deadpool and Breanna
negasonic don't show up to threaten
Francis Gina Carano never gets to do the
superior landing and then you know you
don't have Colossus and Gina battling it
out that's what comic books are so I
don't know what this question was about
you answered it but I'm gonna be quiet
that's that's what I wanted to get to
now switching gears to Deadpool I am
very curious now we're in it and we're
in a new world of comic movies yeah with
a certain acquisition yeah how excited
are we for the continuation of Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool and when what we think
I feel that they paid seventy billion
dollars just for Ryan Reynolds come on
go on you know they did come on one
franchise ended last month another one
didn't well I'm gonna tell you guys you
haven't lived until you're uh I don't
know you guys enjoy yourself at 10
o'clock at night no I've been 51 years
old I have three teenagers I'm not going
to the club cabana at ten o'clock
okay I'm on the couch like this where's
my phone
[ __ ] okay I'm looking at my phone okay
and when your sister my sister she's
older than me
she's old I'm very concerned about my
phone oh there it is damn my phone got
stolen out of my car on Thursday [ __ ]
like my wife had to buy me a new one
before I got here so I don't have a
cover so it's super thin now I see how
thin it is but no literally I want to
pump on my gas you need to hear this I'm
going up to sign contracts for this
profit movie I pull into the gas station
here they in and out in our town and
everyone knows where that ails because
in and out is never gonna not serve you
within 25 minutes it's always a long way
right I'd go to this gas station I pump
and I got to the restroom because now my
gas season have 70 prompts do you want a
certificate of authenticity do you want
a car wash do you want a label do you
want to join our 76 Club no oh my god I
got to go right I run around my car I
open the car to grab my keys I already
got the wallet I run into my car I was
listening to the Pet Shop Boys they're a
band from the 80s okay and I get in my
car after coming out from the restroom I
undo the pump I get in the car and it
goes let because it one note and then
the car said please reconnect your
device please reconnect your device
please Rican I'm like reconnect
reconnect bad shrieking it oh crap
Mike my phones out there it's been
yanked out of its Gordon so I got to go
to LA to sign these documents so I pull
into Starbucks I have my iPad which is
black on a black mat on the side
otherwise they were taking that they
couldn't have seen it
the Kachins snatch-and-grab was so fast
you're like why is he telling us cuz you
need to lock your cars at the gas
station okay I didn't know this I went
to find my iphone in the Starbucks and I
showed it my kid was at the gym my other
guy saw everyone's phones mine's powered
off the criminals were smart enough to
they killed it I called my wife you got
to get me a new phone I'll be back in
six hours
I gotta go to LA blind driving blind no
phone you know how scary that is it
scary
so now I can't feel it but what was
getting to when he asked me is my old
sister told her old brother go on the
Disney website right now you're not
going to believe what you see dude
sitting right there between Robin Givens
the spokesperson of Good Morning America
and a god of ABC news and I think Mickey
Mouse was Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool and
I literally Ted pulls on the Walt Disney
homepage like you haven't lived you have
not lived you have not lived until dead
Deadpool is Center
Mickey you know Mickey Mouse like what
the hell is going on here
and you know like I felt bad for all the
other x-men I did the second
highest-grossing r-rated movie second
only to Jesus only
and now Deadpool sitting next to avatar
here's the deal here's the deal
Hugh Jackman we don't know each other
but if you didn't quit that may it could
have been you but Ryan's like not you
you you abandon ship Dark Phoenix was
made without you
so yeah I know I was very exciting
there's Neil all right are you guys
excited for Deadpool to be a Disney okay
I like your shirt oh you got dead bull
riding Wolverines back is that it oh
okay toe cold got it no I'm gonna tell
you right now I believe so we all saw in
game we all saw in game right because
we're trying to beat avatar is that
gonna work okay James Cameron is sitting
in his space station going muhahahaha
all right guy is a badass mofos everyone
bets against that guy and he goes I made
a blue Alien movie and you can't beat it
Brolin so anyway the I love Josh Josh
will appreciate that and the thing is I
already congratulated on the premiere of
endgame I said Josh congratulations on
being the biggest movie of all time
oh [ __ ] that was pre maybe in August
maybe in August check back in September
no I loved in game we all saw it I saw
it a million times I took my wife and
kids I was so horny to see it the night
of I had already been to the premiere I
already printed I already seen it but I
saw all of you on social media all you
braggadocious I'm not opening that I got
an opening night I said to my wife I've
already seen it I'm jealous
I gotta see it tonight how many of you
opening day at 3 o'clock got your family
tickets for a six o'clock showing and
none of you are sitting together that's
me right now dad of the year
you're going to end game but you're
sitting by yourself you're sitting by
yourself you're sitting by yourself and
you're sitting by yourself let me tell
you something
the best is I I'm not gonna say okay so
my seat is all the way in the back I'm
running up there and there's a family
probably of eight and they got popcorn
in the seat they got kids play toys
there's three kids there's a mom there's
other kids there's a dad and they look
at me like what are you doing and I'm
like that's my seat like I think they
bought a block and they're like but
we're gonna or we're not gonna buy this
one cuz no one will buy a single right
here I bought the single right here get
that popcorn ah I'm so I'm watching
Brolin kill everybody or get killed
whatever look end game we lost some
beloved people right if you had asked me
like six months ago who I wanted to see
Ryan he team up with I just said a
couple of guys that aren't really
possible anymore if you know what I'm
saying right because I'm not going to
spoil things up here but I I think he's
one of the biggest weapons they have coy
I think he's one of the biggest guys in
the Arsenal the Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
Arsenal oh my gosh and you think you
guys they've already told you many times
they're gonna make it are okay they're
gonna it's gonna be our the thing that
impresses me the most is Kevin Feige is
obviously we all bow he needs a church
he needs a at this point it's a city the
city of Feige the man with 20 hit movies
in a row like nothing no one's ever done
it before right not you James Cameron in
your space station but anyway
the thing is for him and Bob Iger who
owns Disney to both publicly say we're
gonna let them do their thing that's not
easy in Hollywood let me tell you for
the president of Star Wars Galaxies land
and because that's what they're gonna
call it Disney right now
no one cares about anything other than
Star Wars Galaxies and Quest whatever I
was at um and I'm never going back
because there's crowds now it scares me
but um the thing is for those two guys
to say Ryan is gonna do his own thing
Khoi knows he lives up in LA he's more
of an LA boy than any of us this this
kid is mr. LA listen to his live videos
his gym everything colliders taking over
I know these guys they're the best
website I guess got to get a plug blood
blood blood blood I've been going to
their site for news for years
Steven whoo sometimes I do interviews
with he's the best he's at junkets all
the time getting you the news and people
like Steven and people like collide and
that's why they tell them stuff that
they'll tell no one else
you heard that from me it's true I think
Ryan is one of the biggest assets assets
that they have he's Canada's ass he put
that out I put that up Monday night when
I said Gretel Toronto you're still in
this because this is Torah I was caught
I came across
we were watching Deadpool again
sometimes we do that at my house
guilty guilty my wife goes I've never
heard that Mario no Pez line so new
things are always coming to us from the
Deadpool to movie when she he says to
Domino I think Mario know Pez so shortly
after that there's a free stream on
Ryan's but that is so amazing I took a
picture that is a juicy but and I think
more juicy then Chris Evans way more
juicier but I don't think that's a
contest anymore right I mean one of them
isn't around to be the ass of anything
anymore
but Ryan is Canada's ass and he's
Canadian okay how did they work that
they got a Canadian to play a Canadian
only in movies people and they shot in
Vancouver they did the whole shoot the
whole damn thing
and have never so gay if you've come
from Canada I so on both movies I'm
picked up and I'm driven to the set of
Deadpool 1 and Deadpool 2 and they do in
Deadpool do they have some stuff on that
same freeway it's the when everyone's in
the prison Bart
you've never seen a city that's more
happy to be inconvenienced that whole
freeway scene whoa I'm gonna fall keep
rolling if I fall I want that um so
here's the deal
that entire freeway scene from the first
one took two weeks to shoot and there
are signs all over the city telling you
the aqueduct they called the aqueduct is
going to be shut down from this 14 days
and they would tell you all miss our
life I was shutting it down for two
weeks what's going up into traffic Oh
terrible Inc you know all these off
roads no one can take that I mean
imagine shutting down a section of the
405 or whatever your most important is
the most important freeway and they were
like yeah but it works because I saw on
ESPN last night then after the Toronto
Raptors won and the city was celebrating
they all waited for the light to turn
green before the entire crowd crossed
they are the Politis group of people
that ever lived on planet Canadiens are
the nicest people they really are so
they shut down a freeway twice and
they're like oh we're so happy to be
inconvenient they're so nice and I
showed you the there's a drink called
the Ryan Reynolds and a bunch of
restaurants they named drinks after Ryan
they name things after Deadpool know the
part of the culture he is the nicest guy
on planet earth which is funny because
he's such a smartass right
i I fear his tongue he is truly dead by
I feel like he really is Deadpool but
anyway I feel like he was born and it
just took 30 years to hand him a suit
that he was made to put on I've always
felt that Deadpool was just coming to
Ryan Ryan Harbor later it was like oh
wait you need this and here we are and
how great is it that he took matters
into his own hands
and and and erased Wolverine Origins
those you know how hard that was to keep
that a secret for six months I knew it I
couldn't say anything I knew that you
guys would flip out and I was there in
the audience when people lost their and
it was great well then the ORA boris of
Deadpool in the Internet is that YouTube
leak got us where we are today
and Deadpool's elected it's a magic
cycle and that leads me to my final
question before I let you play prophet I
know you can't say much but I as a fan
must know what's good like that's
amazing that's today that happened well
yeah you know what here's the deal when
you hear about a movie really and not
get people to announce my movie
announcements I hate that when you read
about it I did not release it I don't
have that power the studio gets that out
there they want to share with you we
have this comic book because those
contracts are a year away from being
signed intellectual property which is
what they call pop comics takes a long
time so Thursday literally like I had a
party I went up I signed my contract I
was so excited I went to meet with the
studio we talked about who could John
profit be I had my ideas of I definitely
like because again as a competitor you
don't want to do something that's
already been done but ya know I'm very
excited could be the first modern age
image movie I know spawn was 25 years
ago but there hasn't been one since well
we have cooking up is great expect the
screen writer and a director very soon
thank you for saying that profit is 26
27 years old great character love him to
death he's all mine soon he'll be all
yours but here's the deal they don't
have a clock running up here it says
zero zero zero zero zero which means am
i talking all night I'm finna tada I
want to go to you guys because you guys
always have the best questions for me
I'm this man now no coy good seen you
thank you my pleasure and before it's
over I need you know what actually
right now Deadpool's if your dress is
Deadpool could you come on the stage
because you're taking this photo come on
Deadpool's you guys put on those amazing
costumes get your I know one of you
can't see you have a hard time keep
walking keep walking
you're good you're good you're no I'm
kidding you I love this guy
he's the best Deadpool cameo is that it
okay ball you're also welcome you look
awesome I love you you actually in two
weeks there's and this major X comes out
and old man cable is in it you'll relate
hey let's have a hand for these people
they put these costumes on and they
entertain you they look amazing okay um
because I'm gonna tell you something
this this is rubber this
these people smell after like 10 minutes
you know when you smell so bad you can
smell yourself like that's and they wear
this all day and it's constricting and
you can see your junk and I mean you
know and you look wonderful I love this
oh I love the combo three billion dollar
movie if that ever happens come on every
kid in America every kid in America
loves venom more than they love anything
so get goin venom oh my gosh balls in
your court Marvel Sony you're awesome I
love you you're the easiest no no I'm
right here shake my in okay okay I know
told you they're blind as hell awesome
you look like you literally walked out
of the screen and cable you a bitchin
can I take this can okay I'm gonna have
this okay okay who's I need a photo
you
zero zero zero zero time left so who's
got a question for me right here be nice
or not I don't care yes they know I
don't have a hard time drawing feet but
it's fun Ryan calls so in dead bull and
they make fun of me which is the it's
awesome I am all over both movies that
is so you know I'm on the Deadpool on
the bar
it says Liefeld those are good odds
because I'm still alive after two movies
there's there's all sorts of references
there so nice to me I'm so honored but
Ryan called me said Rob it's like the
best part about this is like four I
guess they could they could have taken
it out they could have you can take
something out of a movie within 24 hours
hey Rob did anybody from Fox talked to
you about this hey I made this reference
in it out about feet I go I don't care
like here's the thing that people
understand I got three teenagers I've
said this before they take shots at me
all the time you know I can sit down for
breakfast and I get installed insult
insult and salt insulting my kids have
if you only knew the nicknames and for
me you know I mean like Solomon Ryan
Brian Brian whatever you're saying in
that movie isn't as bad as my kids say
to me every day okay
so go with God and then he said if you
haven't seen it I'm sorry you've had a
year to see it his response he goes just
remember Rob I kill myself at the end of
the movie so I'm making front of myself
I'm like you're like a Greek god don't
do you you're not killing yourself
you're ridiculously handsome
particularly tall don't tell me you're
making fun of yourself but it's okay to
make fun of me do more of it I think
it's great
III get very excited also you have to
understand when I pitch Domino to Marvel
because there's that whole da middle
luck powers are stupid when I pitched
they literally said cuz okay you know
you guys who are young fans the truth of
the matter is I had a very six I've had
a very successful career when I was very
young I made all these characters I
turned around a sinking ship called the
New Mutants that
statistical you can look at the sales
chart it was down here I put everything
I had into it as a young kid and it
climbed the charts and went to number
one but I had to change the cast out
that's why i brought cable and domino
and Deadpool and shatters for all these
characters when I handed in Domino's
she's black and white like a domino I
played Domino's sometimes I was bored
I've lined those dominoes up have you
ever played it you know you give a
couple options and when you knock down
the Domino's is it gonna break right
it's gonna break left isn't gonna just
gonna stop so they go rub what she
called Domino she's the Domino but what
does she do I go she's lucky sometimes
she breaks left sometimes she breaks
right things happen for her and I was
paused like yeah that's not good enough
life okay who'd up what do you do I
literally was waiting for them to drop
the hammer on me and tell me that's the
dumbest thing ever and they're like okay
we're good and I'm like yeah like like
at that point because cable had been
sucessful deadblow been so sick they
were just like that's good so in the
movie the fact that they're arguing
about her luck powers the whole time
just cracks me up because I still can't
believe I got it through that easily and
honestly in comics there was a question
on the internet yesterday name a movie
that's better than the book one of the
popular answers and it's true is Planet
of the Apes if you watch the original
Planet of the Apes as I did when I was a
kid then I tried to read the book it's
like algebra might like page five and
not Pierre Bush so whatever your name is
that book sucks
this movie is awesome um and some of the
you know some of the movies are better
um
Chitty Chitty Bang Bang Chitty Chitty
Bang Bang is all way better movie than a
book and you'll see anyway what am I
going with this
I'm totally lost Domino her powers on
screen are better than you could ever
draw in a comic watching that everything
not hit her it's when moving pictures
are better than static pictures and it's
such a great and honestly watching Zazi
be Domino is so spectacular if there's
one thing I am certain of is we will see
more of her very soon
anybody under question I love that this
entire family once asked me questions I
love you you're a cool kid
what's up unless you insult me and then
you're still cool the most painful part
that it wasn't longer I might tell you
right now if you were to watch the movie
with me a couple of times you'd be like
hey mr. Liefeld hey old man my phone why
are you choking up I cry a Deadpool - I
just do because I can't believe the
characters look as good as they do move
as good as they do act as good as they
do and that damn cher song 1989 I am
drawing cables first appearance in New
Mutants 87 that video there's a thing
called MTV you'll it played music videos
you'll go to a museum and hear about it
one day but for kids my age it was like
on all day long I'd be like yeah draw on
MTV move music and pictures it was this
new thing boom bigger than the Internet
at the time there was no internet via
the thing is so I'm drawn cable because
you draw the comics months in advance
and that share video turned back time
was in heavy rotation she was basically
wearing nothing for whatever that year
was it qualified as nothing you were -
loved it you little kid um the and she's
singing on a battleship cruiser and they
didn't know that they couldn't have
known that so when that movie that music
kicks in I get vac limped but Klimt is
another word for I'm a softy I cry all
the time of Deadpool - it's such a great
movie it is I didn't make it but I loved
it okay who's got another question right
here buddy
is that a Star Trek shirt I love it am i
doing anything new for Marvel I have a
ton of new stuff coming from Marvel
major X was just the beginning I have a
sequel to UM so I did a book called
Deadpool bad blood was a graphic novel
the first ever graphic novel for
Deadpool and I thought it was gonna flop
because I think everything's gonna flop
it was 25 bucks it was number one for
the month which honestly I could not
believe and but they were happy to tell
me robbers everyone
awesome those two years ago in
Philadelphia two years ago this weekend
when they called told me that I'm doing
the follow-up to that and then there I'm
gonna tell you right now
major Epps is the little engine that
could you guys made it a hit book I
didn't I just made it
but you guys liked it and sold it out
we've actually reprinted more of the
first issue than we printed up the first
issue and by note hi I love you you're
Colbert guy are you here to tell me that
I need to go do I have more time am i
closing down this show what's going on
um boys just come up and get me when I'm
done what's that mean
okay thumbs up I love this bear kid just
stand here this is cool
okay now I'm kind of nervous like you
okay now you've completely in ten
seconds just going to make any Mervis
but um if you try anything Deadpool
right here he'll tackle you um what was
a question yeah new projects from Marvel
I got a ton of them and there's a couple
things yet some exciting things look
I've had a really great career with
Marvel we've done really well by each
other there's no going they like me I
like them it's good and here's the deal
people understand this I'm in a lifetime
contract with them like when you create
all the characters I've created like you
know I think um we're together for a
long time so anybody anybody in Spyder
and shirts who has a question for me no
okay I just wanted to call it your cool
spider in shorts yes beanie man do I
have any plans to go back to image
comics I'm never leaving Image Comics I
like its I've always got a book there or
in reprints or on digital but I do have
some new stuff coming it'll be next year
I do have a whole bunch of new
characters that are coming but they're
coming next year because I've been
cooking a bunch of stuff up for 10 years
as having a time to get it through
because if I haven't mentioned this 10
times and I say it again I have three
teenagers holy and my youngest my
daughter has taught me the challenges of
a 15 year old daughter and I love her to
death and I'm trying to be the best
parent woo okay love you Olivia
okay who's got another question for me
okay stand up because the Living
Tribunal if you would have told me when
I was a kid that someone would cause
play the Living Tribunal
not a believed it let's give this guy a
hand this is not an easy one to pull off
dude I find me bare dude right on you're
the coolest okay
so uh what do you have what'swhat's
going on there will be more plans for
major X yes 100% there is hey if you
only knew what was coming next
I could excite you to your core I will
not
okay so who's next you right here
besides Deadpool or cable who's my
favorite character I've made all of them
there
all of them I love them all I'm rallying
for shattered star to somehow find his
way back okay so yes bear man bear man
what's up did you rad yes why did I want
to make Deadpool how much time oh he
said why did I want to make dad oh okay
it's really simple you guys knew Muniz
wasn't selling I am you gotta go so who
is Rob Liefeld in 1990 he is 23 22 years
old he is trying to make money I won't
totally pull your heartstrings but my
dad had by the time he his life was over
20 years ago this year he had been
through ten brain surgeries when I was
nine years old he went in for a tumor
and he didn't come home for ten months
he was in a coma and they said you know
pull the plug on him a lot of trips to
the hospital a lot of crying mom I
escaped into comics deeper than than I
ever did but by the time I am in when
I'm 23 my parents are my dad has been
ravaged by multiple
probably his fifth or six brain surgery
which altered him you know he just he
took away the sight of his I took away
most of his voice I am trying to provide
not just for me but my entire family my
parents are financially destitute and I
am trying to provide one
I got I mean I tell my son right now
he's 19 years old he's got a summer job
god bless him he wants to work he wants
to provide for himself
I say Luke when I was your age I was
already a year into drawn comics I was
you know drawn comics and I was living
my dream in that opportunity but I need
to make money because I want to take
care of my parents with my my big
royalty check from x-force I bought them
a new house and put them in a new house
and that was like the most important
thing I had done at that time
so what Deadpool and cable and those
guys meant to me was I need a the short
answer is I need to make money and the
book I was on was was a failing book but
I took it with the challenge that if I
turned around I would reap the rewards
and so when Deadpool and cable I know
this is not really the answer you were
seeking but it's it's really it's really
at the core of all of it
why did I create all these characters I
wasn't out to prove anything other than
to provide for myself the way you make
more money in comics is royalties
anybody will tell you this even in
movies royalties TV it's those checks
that keep coming the rest of your life
that matter so Deadpool appears in 1990
in New Mutants 98 which when I took over
New Mutants sold a hundred thousand
ninety eight cells eight hundred
thousand copies I hate to say this
that's me that is 100% rob liefeld
busting his ass trying to prove turn
this thing around you know if the
climbing for me it's just it's just -
it's I did my job you know what I did I
did my job and that's like I always say
to Marvel I have performed for you I
have done like I take it seriously if
you give me a job I'm gonna try to do
the best job to my best of my ability
one year later they called and said Rob
all your characters are gonna be on the
toy aisles toy biz has stepped in and
they said their favorite x-men
characters are yours I said but they
just put out one line with Cyclops and
Wolverine in the pup in there on there
jumping over 30 years of history and
going straight to yours and I'm like
awesome and so when I saw a Deadpool at
Target and Walmart and there's a place
called Toys R Us also you'll never
remember um
Deadpool Cable they were on the toy
aisles that's because they connected and
sometimes an artist
making a connection with an audience and
Deadpool was part of that connection
cable was part of the net connection
Domino you're like dude I wore this bear
costume but I didn't cry once and I just
told you a sad story and I didn't cry
but um that's the reason I create those
characters was out of necessity that's
the truth I had to keep up with my peers
who had spider-man and Wolverine who are
the two most popular characters in
comics and I did not want to get left
behind because I'm like they're moving
forward at lightning speed
those are super popular characters and
that's why sometimes I just go you know
I was able to make my own destiny and
make my own way but the inspiration for
him was Boba Fett spider-man and Snake
Eyes don't believe any of that other
crap I have a video online you should go
watch when they compare him to the other
character I just think it's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard and I
always say that but it's like those are
my whoa inspirations Spider Man in 1990
was a sad guy I tell my kids go grab a
1990 comic he's almost divorced Mary
Jane's going out dancing every night
he's not funny anymore
spider-man's because the people who were
writing him weren't funny and didn't
have jokes but when I was a kid
Spiderman was funny when he hits you he
made a joke when he wept you he made a
joke in 1990 he ain't funny anymore
he's dark spider-man cuz everything was
going dark dark night everyone wanted me
Frank Miller let's do dark versions so I
said hey Marvel because the guys in the
room I see can I do spider-man with guns
and swords like do it awesome done and
the rest is history
Thank You bear boy one more yes gloved
man
it's Marvel gonna make an animated
series of Deadpool how do I answer this
I get in trouble all the time
I've got it I'm not worried one bit that
there will not be a Deadpool cartoon
very soon I had to perfect that because
you don't know the kind of calls I get I
mean I'm gonna end this I'm gonna end
this right now with my best story from
the last year I won't say you said it to
me
San Diego Comic Con is coming up I go to
San Diego with my buddies in the
industry one of them sits down he's the
last one to get to every meal if I told
you the guys at these dinner you would
be like wow those are cool guys I love
it we are going on our 12th anniversary
of having this dinner at Comic Con I'll
do this he comes and sits down thanks
Rob what I do now really really you got
a you got a say Donald Glover is a
genius and I'm so sad we're not getting
his Deadpool show really am I supposed
to lie like we all know Donald Glover is
a genius I would have loved to seen that
show what am I saying wrong to you
thanks Rob no thank you
like we would have had a Donald Glover
cartoon by now
right okay hello so anyway what did I
say I am NOT I have no doubt that we
will have a jet that there will not be a
Deadpool cartoon in the news in the near
future there I reiterate it twice
because I'm gonna read this on some
tweet in about 20 minutes
and I got to be careful because twitter
has become a hell it's a hellhole if I
was gonna crit there's Deadpool in there
cesspool and I hang out in the cesspool
I'm guilty I'm guilty Instagram you know
what's funny I broke that chair the head
of Instagram comes up to me a WonderCon
I don't know he's a head a Instagram
he's got Deadpool comics and he goes hi
mr. live only hands okay I'm gonna tell
you something I have another son he gets
crap from Instagram all the time I get
dick they don't send me candy they don't
send me anything my son gets giant
packages from insta gonna cause he's an
influencer oh he's gonna be so mad at me
um I'm like really you get [ __ ] from
Instagram he's an inch to youth there's
some crap it's cuz he can't keep his
shirt on um but the thing is I go you
get candy and pops and all this stuff so
the Instagram guy comes up to me I don't
know some Instagram he puts his head he
hands me his card
I'm blah blah blah head of Instagram I'm
like wow hate him instagramming goes we
love you mr. Liefeld we think here I go
then why don't you send me stuff like
you said my kid my kid gets ultra oh I
don't know about that is he an institute
I'm a inste 51 year old like show
respect but he goes we love you on our
platform like all thanks I love it I go
man Twitter like let's get brutal and he
goes
and that's like that's awesome so now I
always think of him going so mister
Liefeld learned that day go hang out on
Instagram
it's about Twitter is like storming the
beach at Normandy like they're shooting
at you like so now I've only gone to
retweeting things retweet but yeah I'm
gonna read about this later
Internet's dangerous it's dangerous for
old men like me so they've tried to
they've tried to punish me you can't
give me more so many people have tried
to hurt me in 30 years and I'll just
leave it at that
okay so one more question because they
said I had eight minutes so I have two
questions I'm sorry if I bored you I'm
just stream-of-consciousness
all the way in the back you're waving at
me what's your question yeah
come up here
go ahead I'm Rob nice to meet you you
mentioned seeing Domino in the future
are we talking separately or with others
oh no I believe you'll see her more in
the Deadpool movie her question is do
you think Domino when you mentioned
you'll see more or do you think we'll
see more of her in the movies that's
what I'm talking about
but I'm pretty sure that if there's a
Deadpool cartoon that is probably likely
gonna happen sometime in the near future
that you'll see her there too and I like
Harlequin - yeah Darwin shirt on okay
yes power ranger you like that okay let
me have your knife okay no I don't want
you to hurt me so go ahead check this
out here you go
thank you he asked me the Power Ranger
what officially is your name no no the
Power Ranger thank you um okay Power
Ranger I don't know that stuff my kids I
need my kids he asked me um
will there be a Deadpool video game how
is there not another Deadpool video game
right it was ahead of its time they
almost didn't sell it to me at GameSpot
I've told that story a million times but
I see that he's in Ultimate Alliance
okay true story my kids did not know
about Deadpool into Ultimate Alliance no
in case you ever create something cool
you're not gonna like you will not when
your kid is five or six go dad so cool I
created this character you're not gonna
do that that's not what happens
I don't think Mark Hamill told his kids
at six yeah I'm Luke I don't think that
happens my kids got Ultimate Alliance in
like 2005 2006 he was like an unlockable
character and one day I came over and
all the kids of the neighborhood are
fighting over Ultimate Alliance and
playing Deadpool and unlocking Deadpool
and then one year later they did the
Deadpool vs. they kicked a lot it was a
bunch of anime care um
Capcom oh my gosh that was like tank cuz
we had the big screen we had the cool
system all the kids hung out and they
would fight over who would be Deadpool
true story Robert Kirkman Walking Dead
Robert Kirkman walks in we were going to
see a movie and he's really good at
video games I am NOT and they and my one
son who thinks he's the [ __ ] talks crap
to Kirkman like you don't I'm playing in
a scratchy Jess Roberts I really alright
can I can I sit down what my son's out
woof Kim just slaughtered him I'm like
all right good to see ya good to see you
Luke there's my son humiliated in front
of all of his because this bearded guy
just wiped the floor with him but they
discovered dead both Ravinia games he
had that run of like he was even in a
spider-man game on one level like
Deadpool in video games so now I sealed
two middle lines three and he's like in
the back I'm like what he doing get him
to the front I'm prejudiced I'm bias
okay he's done very well with video
games yes I hope there is I believe
there is Red Ranger okay one more
question four minutes and then I'm out I
think out of the restroom anybody light
but we want to see you wet your pants
right here it's gonna happen
you yes you Raider man
his question is there's been rumors that
Ryan Reynolds would appear in a
spider-man movie and what I get behind
it um nobody wants to see spider-man and
Deadpool more in the movies than me I
figured that out like but honestly who
more than Rob Liefeld I opened this by
saying every time you buy out dead bull
thing you are contributing to the
Liefeld College Fund and I thank you
do we think Deadpool would be more
popular with spider-man or less popular
more popular like so look here's the
thing I just see I honestly said explain
that to me explain to me how that works
Sony has the movie rights to spider-man
here's what I don't believe I don't
believe they paid seventy billion
dollars for Deadpool because that's the
D they were buying okay to go say hey
Sony we love you guys you get the first
appearance of dead but none of that
works not to me
I don't know that tile it works now do I
want Deadpool in every Marvel movie from
now on to the end of time yes just like
you and don't act like you don't I read
your comments you people are super
creative I go wow Deadpool sure to run
through this scene an end game yet
[ __ ] a minute here and Deadpool you
guys are way more creative than all the
rest of us because you're fans and you
have better ideas amazing ideas I do
wonder like what would Deadpool and
Ruffalo as Hulk be like would it be
better with dumb Hulk or better with
smart Hulk dumb Hulk would it would Paul
Rudd and Ryan Reynolds break the
internet together like you know right so
I'm like you I'm a fan I'm a fan but I
mean I honestly yes there's no there's
like there's only like I said endgame
we're losing characters here like so now
we've got a who's on the ledger that's
alive okay so Paul Rudd you're funny
Mark Ruffalo you're funny Ragnarok
you're in space you know I mean like
Hemsworth is like the last MVP but he's
off with the raccoon so I don't know how
you could did pull up there I think
about this I have two minutes yes I want
spider-man and Deadpool more than life
itself do I think it's going to happen
soon No
do I hope I'm wrong yes
because people who you're rooting
against it like what how I'm go back to
them how am i rooting against it but the
internet doesn't like logic if you put
logic it pisses them off and Anthony
Davis is a Laker now and that should
puts everybody off yes I'm a Laker fan
hate me
go ahead hate me okay who else do more
one more I had your whole family so
let's do you
let's do you matrix I had 30 years ago
true story
people go back and look at the original
movie Mad Max Mel Gibson Mad Max 1979
the movie poster it's one of those movie
posters that does a trick Aroo they
speed all the time go see the original
Mad Max movie poster oh I'm a dilly fall
you guys are rooting for it almost
happened stand back here watch this good
collapse on the movie poster of Mad Max
is this badass guy with a motorcycle
helmet and a gun and it looks awesome
that never appears on the movie that is
not in the movie
in 1970 I'm like I didn't see that once
like I didn't see that once but it's a
good movie but I always said I want to
do a badass guy in like a motorcycle
helmet and so a funny thing is like ten
years ago I said hey mr what could I
come back to that major X and that
editor at The Times like nay I didn't
fight I'm like okay maybe next time
I just I'm a visual guy I wanted to do
an X man with an X on his face with a
motorcycle helmet who has a motorcycle I
accomplished all that it connected with
you guys thank you but it goes back to
Mad Max people try and outdo me and they
go loops are Judge Dredd life oh I
missed the power where he is an open
mouth and stubble like I just people
come at me sometimes I'm like I'm
telling you where it came from that Mad
Max poster go look at it you go life hub
is not lying to me that is exactly it
just took me 30 years to implement it
nine eight seven
six I'm gonna ask one more question I'm
coming back I mean one more okay if you
could put Deadpool in any movie in the
history of cinema Avatar the number one
movie of all time
let's give it up for Rob Liefeld always
a pleasure thank you thank you guys so